o jogador do uol encontrado escudo
miguel monteiro voltou a jogar o ó
escudo está já a fazer liga monteiro
como a i love to book desculpa de que
está tudo bem e saíram calma tem de
ficar uma amiga
miguel monteiro não sabe estimar seus
coisas não é inimiga número um
a nota diz que tem várias coisas estão
mal é meu e eu quero fazer bem o seu
papel para horas eu paro pra eu falei
para elas eu parou para olhar para todas
as folhas hoje quando fui eu pensei que
era uma desculpa desculpa é um canteiro
não fugi miguel monteiro
fiquei quieto com a cemig
o objetivo do milho é um desejo ea
monteiro miguel monteiro está rindo
moura torre para olhar minha ontem o
nome da [ __ ] quase do tamanho da missão
mas miguel monteiro não podem ser
[Música]
desculpa de que comece um vídeo miguel e
se o gol não sair com um bom eu não
tenho como assim que ela quer com essa
merda monteiro está sorrindo
canto nos meses e medo porque não sabe
declarou miguel pronto para isso mas
sabemos que aqui cruzamento porque julgo
que o meu
o preto no branco a tv
então minha mãe não mais voltar a jogar
igual à taxa quitada está a sorrir
miguel miguel monteiro estádio jogaram
ao é de excluir a qual é coletivo na
europa mostra mostra mostra mostram as
duas sociedades de investimento caíram
pai o cantor puto tivéssemos eu não
trago o meu eu tenho na água meu fundas
então eu tenho na água por causa disso
eu tinha um terno está tudo bem contigo
desculpa desculpa série desculpa eu
chutaria
não tá tirando nota batina eu só tô
várias altas ao saltar um espaço
singular cara vai só tem uma educativa
não tenho